let's go next to Meg from Seattle Meg
welcome
hi David thanks for taking my call my
pleasure
um
so uh you've probably heard the uh the
phrase that there's no ethical
consumption under capitalism
um I was wondering do you agree with
that Gary
uh no I mean listen in general I don't
agree with almost any of these
overarching absolutes for such broad
statements there is no ethical
consumption under capitalism I mean
listen you can you can argue that that's
the case and you can argue that you know
they're they're hardcore free marketeers
who say the only ethical system is free
market capitalism I find it so
unproductive to argue about such
overarching broad statements like I'm
more interested in figuring out how can
we improve the economic system we have
so that it works better for more people
and raises up uh the standard of living
and gets more people health care and uh
rewarding well-compensated jobs I I just
don't know that we get there by arguing
about whether there's any ethical
consumption under capitalism to me it
really seems like a distraction
I I think that's a good point
um and I'm guessing you don't have time
to go into you know what alternate you
know uh what alternatives you know you
would uh propose to capitalism like you
said you you're more interested in you
know looking at what we can do to make
things better yeah no I mean listen Meg
the the the general Outlook I have is
that social democracy in the style of
many northern European uh countries is
the direction I would like to go I'm
okay with markets directing resources in
many areas I'm okay with there being you
know a film and television live
streaming uh Private Industry and
decisions being made by private
companies about what to produce and then
selling it to Netflix or Hulu or what
like I'm okay with that I think that
that's okay I don't need to socialize
every industry but also we need to be uh
regulating in industry significantly for
the betterment of our planet we need to
be taxing the very rich in order to fund
programs to make sure that no one drops
below a certain standard of living we
need to be taking certain industries out
of the market and that includes health
care and others you know I mean that's
my general view of how I would structure
things to improve from where we are now
absolutely I mean our economic system is
just one piece well very big piece but
of all the the systems that aren't
working
uh that are pretty broken right yes
absolutely absolutely yeah so like I'm
more interested in that than like is
there ethical consumption under
capitalism call me crazy Meg
sure sure uh quick follow-up um you know
I've also heard it say that you know
that we're in like late stage capitalism
and I'll be honest I haven't done a huge
amount of research on that specifically
but do you agree do you think we're in
late stage capitalism
um I I have absolutely no idea is the
that's you know there's this whole
movement that makes that claim
um I think we just have to wait and see
and we things are sort of unprecedented
in that modern humanity is uh a tiny
fingernail on the wingspan of how long
humans have been on this planet and
countries
um the size and power of today's
superpowers are also uh basically
unprecedented and so we are in New
Territory and I don't know it could be
that this is that that we're going to
continue improving on capitalism for the
next thousand years it could be that
capitalism is 20 years from collapse I
have absolutely no idea
okay well thank you so much for taking
my call David thank you Meg important
questions which I very much appreciate
hearing from you